okay
so we can start with the introduction hi
everyone
uh my name is noah i'm a culture
co-chair of pi data berlin and we have
here also tia and valentina from the pi
data building team
um as far as i can see
maybe some others um danielle
who danny daniels hi daniel
um yes we are phi data berlin
uh we are um
yes we are the building chapter of pi
data and phi data
as some of you may have heard before is
dinam is the
educational program of non-focus and we
will talk about
we it will be introduced very soon
our program for today is me
i am your introduction happening now and
then we have
two very cool thoughts um one is from
catia fro flores posa we'll talk about
um controlling many satellites at the
same time
and then we will we will have the second
talk from niladri
check her dude about deep fake
and why he has trust issues um let's
hope he can solve them the song
yeah some of them today in between we
will have a five minute break
and at the end we can all meet up in
this
nice platform called wonder um it's kind
of a special
chat thingy similar to gather town where
you can walk on your screen and talk in
smaller groups and chat
and later we will post in the chat the
link so we can all
gather there later
this meetup is recorded so both
talks are recorded and are also streamed
now in youtube so please take it into
consideration
um for both talks if you have any
questions please write them down in the
chat
and we will pass them on for the speaker
at the end of the
of their talk also if you are watching
on youtube you can also
write down the questions in the youtube
chat and we will pass them on to the
speaker
so yeah as i mentioned we are pi data
building we are the local
chapter of pi data which is kind of a
worldwide thing
we started in 2016 and we had
quite a lot of fun meetups and
conferences every
uh ever since uh we are announcing it up
every third wednesday of the month you
probably found us on meetup.org and you
can just register and come to all of our
meetups sometimes these questions
comes up we are all volunteers here so
doing it not clear why
but yeah no one pays for that
we have a code of conduct which is the
non-focus code of contact
in short be kind to each other and
please remember that the code of conduct
applies also when we are
online um yeah and
if you are in berlin and you are
interested in python and you like
and you would like to contact and get in
touch with other people who are
interested in python you're
welcome to join the python berlin stack
there's also a data science channel
that you can follow and also handling
there are job posts there or you can ask
technical problems um
yeah so we're gonna start now with the
first talk
um this is us by databellin you can
follow us on twitter
and this is our website um
i will stop the show now it is sharing
the screen
and i think valentina will introduce our
first speaker
yeah hi everyone i'm valentina also
co-organizer of pi data
i have the pleasure to introduce my
colleague katya who will be speaking
about
uh how planet operates more than 100
satellites using
using agile aerospace um
katja is the lead of the space
operations team for
planet um and she has a background in
telecommunication engineering but also a
passion for space
and uh she has been working in the space
operations for the last
seven years so she's been scaling
operations
from starting for from five satellites
to
more than 300 satellites launched
to date so katya
welcome thanks valentina and thanks to
pi data for having me
um so let me
share my screen
all right yeah
so um i'm gonna talk today
through what does it mean to operate
satellites and then what does it mean to
operate
uh hundreds of them um so
yeah as valentina mentioned i'm the team
lead of the space operations
uh group of planets so we are actually a
small team of people
less than ten um i just
i want to start off like with showing
you
what does the constellation that we
operate look like i think
visual way is the best way to do it um
thanks right um so this is a
day in the life of the dove so we call
our satellite
doves um because they remind
remind us to that they have two wings uh
so
yeah we just we call them doves and then
a group of satellites we will call them
flocks
so basically what our sites are doing
they are taking uh their earth sensing
um a remote sensing satellite so they
are taking pictures
of our earth continuously um exactly as
the simulation shows so um they are
acting like a line scanner so it's like
having
uh multiple cameras on the same plane
different planes
um just doing that taking images of
landmass as they pass over the
the earth and having that constellation
on the space
allows us to take um daily images of the
entire landmass of earth
and by having all that data then we are
able to
inform decision makers and provide um
the visibility on the changes that
happen on the day-to-day that
uh weren't there available before
um all right so i wanna give you a quick
overview to
what our constellation of satellites
look like
um so we had actually three types of
satellites
um so i when i started working on space
operations
um i was working with the rapid eye
constellation
so those are five satellites the size of
a fridge um
and they were launched on 2008 and they
have been taking images
uh up to 2020 so last year
so we have this huge archive of data um
for all these years from this
constellation and of course um
even though they were designed to last
six to seven years they
um outgrow that that period of time so
they continue taking images even years
after
uh but it reaches a point where um you
know that
there's such degradation that we we
wanted to make sure that we had the
capability of
um lowering their orbit so that they
could be safely
um and safely re-enter the atmosphere
within a
time that is responsible um and then
then we have the doves and superdope so
we have two generations
of satellites and that's why we call
them super dope superlofts are the
latest iteration of our sets um so we
have launched to date
more than 300 of these and we currently
have in orbit
uh more than 180 of these sets so
to give you a sense of the scale um how
different these stats are
to the rapid eye so the rabbit eye are
like a mini fridge
and the doves are like a shoebox size so
30 by
uh by 10 centimeters um like yeah
they're very small but they have um very
similar capabilities so
they take images um what we call medium
resolution so that means
a pixel is equivalent to three meters
um something that will be three meters
on ground um and then they they
image the earth on different bands so
there are the visual bands that we see
red green blue and then additional bands
that will help us identify
things like vegetation um yeah
vegetation
indices uh that will help for
agriculture
detection for example um and then we
have a constellation of high resolution
satellites these are
we currently have 21 in space and these
are about the same size
as the rabbit eyes also like a mini
fridge but these ads have the capability
of
taking like really high resolution
images so um sub
sub meter resolution um
okay so that's what we have on space so
it's like having all these cameras
around like orbiting the earth
um so what system do we need to
actually talk to the satellite and then
make sure that we are
getting health data from them and that
we are getting all those pictures that
they are taking down
um so this is in a nutshell what our
system looks like
um so there's the space segment so which
is all this group of satellites uh and
then we
of course have radius on board of them
so that we can talk to
two ground stations on earth um and
because we have such a large number of
satellites
on space we also need a large number of
ground stations
on the ground so operations is not only
about taking care of the satellites that
are
on space but also taking care of the um
of the systems on ground that support
the space system um so
i'm gonna go into the detail on on the
radio frequencies and all but there are
like
uh to simplify there are two types of
communication so
a low speed one and a high speed one so
with low speed communication we can get
health data from the satellites and
upload commands to them
and with high with high rate
radius then we download you know all the
images which are
um a larger amount of data
um and then we need systems that will
orchestrate
how each of these resources are used
like um
to which satellites each antenna talking
how many times a day
what is each satellite doing on a given
day like where is it taking images
um when it's supposed to point to the
ground station to download data and when
it's supposed to point to
to the ground and actually take a
picture um so those systems
are also built in house um so for us
so there is a scheduler that will make
sure to
conflict those resources um there is
mission control
um you probably um have in mind the
picture
you know like in the latest um
mars rover landing you see like
a lot of monitors each of them
monitoring a subsystem
and then engineers behind them um
you know sending the commands and make
monitoring the telemetry that comes from
the spacecraft so
basically that's what mission control
does but in a different setup
so mission control for us is built on
the cloud
so um and it doesn't have a lot of
people sitting 24 7
in front of them to monitor the sets so
that is possible because we have
a lot of automation in place and i'm
going to elaborate more on that later
but just just to have the the the two
differences so
mission control for me is like now i'm
sitting at home in berlin
and i can access it through my laptop or
like from my couch
and then i can command the satellites
from there um
and then of course we need um
like a place where we store all the data
that comes down so we have
logs we have telemetry we have pictures
and we want to make sure that
all these systems are built such that we
can build on top of them
so that they all have endpoints that we
can query that data
uh with other scripts that will run on
top um so
those were designed from the very
beginning with that in mind
um yeah and then we have a different
what we call pipeline for
for the images uh that's different
storage where
each of the pictures get processed and
there's some quality checks in between
all of that
automated because daily we have um daily
we download more than
15 terabytes of data so we have to
process all that data
of course in a very automated way um
yeah and then once the images go through
all that processing pipeline and image
quality checks then they get published
and delivered on a platform that are
that our customers can
can access um
cool so how we do all of that and
of course this wasn't like the picture
at the beginning um
so we we use agile aerospace and
everything but
what does agile airspace mean so it's on
its core is rapid iteration
um so on everything so from
manufacturing the satellites to
um iterating quickly on the software the
satellites are running on the software
that we are running around
um on how we do testing um so
one good example of rapid iteration is
um
these doves um it was actually not just
one model
uh so we have had more than 13
iterations over time now we are
past 13. um so what we do is
um put some new components put the new
software
um launch a take them or test it on
orbit and if that works then
that will become the next um the next
version to launch
so that's how we have been able to
progress very quickly and get like
always the latest and best packed into
these
three unit cubesat form uh over the
years
um and that also that also happens on
um on the software side so the way we
we process the data from space operation
and space operations point of view
to now has changed following that um
that agile our space mentality
um and a key part of this when trying to
do this
um is also always building the tools
with that in mind um with
with having a scalability online knowing
that okay
now we are operating 20 sets but in a
year we might have 200 on orbit
um so that makes things easier and makes
the system
just robust to handle what
what comes on the road map um
and i want to make a pause on talking
about agile to
go get into something exciting which is
this is also agile
and so to have that large number of
satellites on the space you need to
launch them uh and launchers are also
uh well no now the market is growing but
it's it's something
like constraints right there only enough
launchers in the world
so we need to make sure that um we are
launching as often as we need
um so this is just a snapshot of what
the year looked like
looked like for us like the last year um
so we had
uh lunches
okay thanks um yeah so we
launched from a european rocket the vega
there we had 26 of our newest doves
which we call super doves um and then
something interesting of that rocket is
we had two different deployers
um so the satellites get deployed um
from what we call uh quad quad pod so
it's basically like boxes with a spring
that
released the sats but there were two
different of those systems on board so
that was something new for us um and
then we launched
six of our high resolution sky sets um
with spacex
uh we actually had yeah two spacex
languages one electron
and one vega actually two electrons um
yeah so
just that's another part that is also
agile you know using as many
opportunities as we can to get
sats into space and to give you an idea
of the amount of data that we have to
deal with
um the global ground station network
last year collected over five petabytes
of data
um yeah and our most recent lunch was
actually on january
um i put this because this was very
exciting uh so it was a record-breaking
uh launcher uh you probably have seen
um i don't know if but i always see the
the live transmissions from any um any
rocket launch but
this was a spacex record-breaking one
because this was the
most uh small sets ever launched all
together
so 143 satellites were put all together
on this rocket and they all
had the same right and so here we
launched 48 superdopes
so also on two different two different
deployers
and this was our 30th successful branch
so far and this is one of the images
that
one of our sites that were launching
that on that rocket
took right after being commissioned
cool uh now i'm gonna talk about how
they operate so the concept of
operations so that you have an idea of
what we have to do as a space operations
and for automation
um so our doves are a monitoring mission
so monitoring means they are always
taking pictures
uh over landmass um because that's their
point of interest
um and then like if they are not taking
images then they are
talking to the ground stations and
downloading that data
and when they are not doing either of
those two things um
to be able to have them as a line
scanner separated like in the video we
need to phase them out
so space them out along the orbital
plane
and to do that we use um differential
drag maneuvers
so like the satellite will be rotating
so that um
the atmospheric drag will affect its
position in relation to the others and
they will slowly separate
uh among the plane so those three things
uh so it's pretty simple
um well it sounds simple um but yeah
that's basically what the sets uh have
to do um and one important thing
to mention is like um we don't do 24 7
off so there's not a person there
looking what each satellite is doing all
the time
and that's because uh we have a lot of
automation in place
um so what we call nominal operations
is basically all the tasks to make sure
that the satellite is healthy
and it's doing what it's supposed to do
so for us that you know it's
it's able to take pictures and it's
taking pictures and it's able to
download them to the ground stations
and it's downloading them um so the
first
thing of all is like how do you tell the
satellite what to do um so there comes
the scheduler so the scheduler is
um an optimizer building house that will
everyday
um you know score
um areas of the of the la of the
landmass that each of the satellite can
best and can better
take a picture of and then like that
combined with the power budget of the
satellite will just distribute
um images imaging activities we call
them so
slots where the sets are taking images
to each of them and
to the whole constellation and then
based on like how many
pictures a satellite has taken so it has
a lot of other parameters and then it
optimized for
how to better distribute all the
available time
um that the ground stations have so the
scheduler will take care of doing that
autonomously um it runs daily
uh many times a day um so that's one
thing so there doesn't have
we don't need an operator or a person
like deconflicting or creating
um schedules for the satellites um
yeah so that's very important also
important not only for the space segment
but also for the ground
network so we have more than 40 antennas
distributed
across the world so it will be just
unsustainable to have
you know persons dedicated on each of
them in each of the locations
and also the they have to act as a
network
um and then we need to know how each of
the satellites are doing so
once they are talking to the ground
station that data will come down
um and instead of like you know looking
at each of those
um each of that data and just to give
you an idea
um our ground stations run more than
2000 passes a day
so yeah it needs to be automated
um and also the way the images are
processed so
um yeah so let me talk about
what are our tasks so i can go more into
detail on the automations
um so what's the space operation so from
the moment um
the satellites are manufactured on
ground and then they're put on a rocket
and then they are launched so as as soon
as they leave the deployer
of the rocket and they are in space um
that's where our task
starts um so we
as a space-offs are responsible of the
commissioning of those slats
commissioning means
making sure that all the subsystems are
working as expected
um be tumbling the satellite so because
when they are deployed
they are tumbling at the given rate so
we want to make sure that we have
um the attitude controlled um that we
check that the radius working that the
camera is working so all of that process
needs to be done for each of these
satellites um and as soon as we can
um so for that we have also building
automations and
actually this last launch was one of our
best commissioning
process so we something that would take
in the past
um more than a week to do so
commissioning will last like per
satellite about seven to ten days
um we managed to achieve that uh to
reduce that to
to less than two days and that's because
we built in automation on board and also
on ground
um so once the satellites are
commissioned and they are starting to do
you know what they have to do taking
pictures and downloading uh
we move into a monitoring stage so we
have to monitor that
and not unexpected things are happening
that anomalies
are being resolved or are being caught
um and then at the same time
as part of our um agile aerospace we
will continuously test things on orbeez
so
call them experiments or testings um so
obviously we have
um testing on ground so we have
satellites on on grounds where we test
things first but we also
testing some space so we have uh
we call them canaries so they're like
the um or staging stats that that's
where we will test something first to
make sure that
everything's fine and then roll to the
hopefully
um and then anomaly debugging of course
so when something comes up and we need
to fix it
uh we need to look into it uh but we are
also working towards making this more
autonomously
um then yeah uh software uh we
continuously
update the software that is running on
board the satellite
so that's a big part of testing on
ground and also testing on orbit
and then when the satellites reach their
end of life then there is a retirement
process
but it doesn't end there so once the
satellite is no longer
productive and we have had to retire it
there is a lot of data
from that satellite so from their whole
lifetime and that that data will help us
create models
degradation models or forecast models um
what to expect from next from next
generation satellites
all right so um moving into how space
operations change
with the amount of satellites um so
obviously some years ago
we had attend even um probably a bit
less now
of the of the amounts of satellites that
we have now um
although mission control was built in
for scalability there have been um
already many iterations so
but the the principle the principal
feature was that we wanted to have a
mission control that would be able to
talk to the ground stations and handle
the communication with the satellites on
its own
so that was a key stepping stone
um and then the first satellites that we
launched
um were a way of us
a way for us as space operations to
learn um
you know like what data we should be
looking at so basically gather
operational experience
um so initially what what our job looked
like was
going through uh reports so logs that
um capture things that were happening on
ground or things that were happening um
on board the satellite uh and then we'll
have some sort of
um scripting that will filter or group
things
um like similar warnings or similar
captures and then we'll
we'll have that summary per satellite
and then an operator
one of us will have to look it into each
of those alerts and then understand or
understand the root cause and then come
up with a mitigation
um so we would look at that daily per
set but of course
as the number of sets increased that
became um
unsustainable um yeah
it was time consuming you need to
evaluate every alert and as we were
constantly iterating there were
new um new things or new features on the
satellite so
there were different performance value
across satellites and of course as the
number increased there was more data to
parse through
so um i remember there were days where
like it took us half a day of a working
day to go through
all of the alerts um and now it takes us
less than an hour
um so what changed so we had to move
from the traditional space operations
mentality of
let's look at what happens with each
individual set to
what do we expect from the whole fleet
um so we
shift that on our minds and say okay
let's first look at the value of the
constellation so
what is important is that as a whole as
a group these satellites have to deliver
this amount of data
and they have to download it within this
time
so what we look at now is um
we build metrics with scripts
that will aggregate that data for us and
that will be the first indicator if the
fleet as a whole
it's operating as it should and then
if not then we know there is a
fleet-wide issue
and then we have built alerting systems
for those metrics that matter the most
to us and we will only react to those
alerts then
and then the second layer is identifying
um the doves or the sets on the fleet
that have some
non-nominal behavior but we don't want
to do that by looking at each of them
so what we want is for the metrics to
tell us
we we expect this performance from this
ad
but there has been this deviation and
then we just want to see the alert
and we want to see the alert on the
specific thing that we have to look at
um so that's what we have now and then
the next step
is like okay now we know this alert on
this
specific issue has pop-up how do we
mitigate this
uh so once we have the mitigation path
we want the next time this happens
that we have a script on top we have a
script that detects the issue
and then we have a script that just
applies the resolution
automatically so without us knowing but
of course we we want to have visibility
on how many times this happens so
we make sure to build metrics around
everything our automations
um on the performance um
so by doing this we optimize the system
availability and the capacity because
there is less engineering time spent at
looking at individual things
investing in automation frees up a lot
of our time on that and then
makes the responses way quicker and so
rather than a person looking for
something
and then some there's some delay time
between like okay coming up with the
response and applying the response
the um the automation is just taking
care of that
taking care of that immediately um so
that has been
that has been a great positive change um
so yeah i talk a lot about metrics um
so i mean this is a very simple diagram
of what we have in place
um as space operations uh but it's
basically that
so we have the different entities of the
system so we have mission control
that has data from each of the
satellites and each of the ground
stations
uh we have orbit data from the sets we
have telemetry we have logs
and all of these data is stored in such
way that we can
um that we have end points to query that
data from
so it's easy for us uh to build a
scripts on top um we use python for this
we have a lot of scripts that
like a a group of them that we call
mission metrics that will tell us
everything from the high level
performance of the of the fleet to
like specific um performance data per
satellite
and per subsystem so it just gives us
the granularity that we need and also it
abstracts to
um true high-level metrics um and then
we
we can decide how to use this data
that's the great thing so we can
from there you know use those aggregated
records
and then build automated responses on
top do analysis on
python notebooks or simply like display
the data on
visual ways like using tools like
grafana or kibana
so it just is just like a very powerful
way of
using data analysis on any issue that
can come up
um yeah so over the years
and i would say especially the last two
years or so
um yeah the the role of the space ops
operator
has been taken over by the automation
and so
um we call it out the wall but it's not
it's that's why the the logo here but
the automation has taken that role
uh so it takes care of the common
anomalies and maximizes the
performance of the fleet um
cool and this is one a specific example
of one of the automations
this might be going into too much detail
and actually one of my colleagues talked
about this specific use case on pi data
about more than a year ago now so
maybe it's time for us to do another
deep dive on this but
um this is just one clear example of
where automation is
is just very important um so
we use we use a job that sets that
on the duty cycle on each satellite
so the duty cycle is how many times in a
day
the satellite will spend imaging uh
the earth so it only can do so much
because there's only so
so much land to to take pictures of and
also because there's only so much power
um so the power depends uh because we
have solar panels
the power depends on um the sun and the
sun beta and also
across the stations in a year that angle
changes
um so we want to make sure that our
power models and the duty cycle
includes that change so the lower the
rectangle the lower illumination the
panels have so
um the lower the power it's available to
the satellite so we want to make sure
that
we know that and the satellite knows
that so that it's not
overdoing itself like it's not trying to
take more pictures with the power that
it doesn't have
um so this is obviously um
it will make sense to do this manually
and like checking
every time of the year when we have to
change this so basically that's what an
automation is doing is just
um checking the power telemetry saying
okay this
the the voltages on board look look okay
if there is a dip
and a flag has trigger on the power
system then it will say oh you're doing
you're doing much more than what you
need to do so let's reduce your duty
cycle
so it's doing that tuning for us and by
doing that we're keeping the satellite
healthy and we are also making sure that
uh when we have a lot of power we are
imaging as much as we can
and when not we are dialing it back
um cool so yeah that's just one example
of
the many things that we have to control
but that are just made easy
by having uh ready available metrics
that we can aggregate
in any way we can um yeah and then build
on top of that
so what's next um so we have reached
that point where we feel comfortable
with
um you know like the the the detection
and mitigation and the metrics that we
have uh and now
we are trying to explore with machine
learning applications so we have
all these data already aggregated in
many ways
um so what we are trying to discover is
how we can
make make use of that historical data
altogether
um so what we have in mind like
maybe in the long term it's being able
to predict the anomalies
so we know some signatures um we have
the data
of all the subsystems and we we also
have operator data
when an anomaly has happened like as an
operator as a human
what what are the things you had looked
at um so training the
training those data sets with that um
might help us be more predictive
and also predict performance degradation
so we know okay
we have a better model for forecasting
uh and eventually um just
having an autonomous fleet that requires
no human in the loop
um that's like the ultimate goal but um
yeah we're not there yet but those are
some next steps
um cool and i wanted to learn because i
talked a lot about space and launches
but
um why is this important so abstracting
a bit from the technical side of things
um and actually these are some
applications that you know where
python or any type of data analysis is
super powerful
uh it's to play not play but to actually
use the data that comes down from the
satellites
um so to me this is a very oops sorry
and this is a very powerful uh video
that
shows what can be observed um so this is
data
from um this is an image from the amazon
forest from 2017 uh till last year
so because we have daily images you can
see how things change
across time um
yeah so it's just uh i think it's just
powerful and it's something um
that adds this visibility that we didn't
have before
um yeah you can see the deforestation
how it's increasing across the days
yeah i mean it's very sad but yeah
this is a really good example of the
impact that our data can make
and of the applications of earth
observation imagery in general
um cool thanks um of course uh
there's some time for questions i think
i might have extended myself a bit but
if you are excited about what we do
about space uh
anything space operations data analytics
um you know we are hiring a lot so
check out our career pages or let me
know if you want to know more
thanks
thanks a lot katya was very interesting
i'm biased okay
um we'll do
uh theo or noah help me with the
questions we have questions both in
youtube
and i guess here
i please write your question in the chat
if you have any we have a question from
youtube
which uh what is the lifespan of these
satellites
from large to their retirement
yeah so the design life is up to three
years uh but
we have definitely scenes as that have
lived more than that
thanks i see a question are there
images available to the public
um there are three different programs um
so
just recently we signed up
an agreement with the norway government
it's called nifky
um so that's opening data for uh
forests around the world so there are
different ways where the data can be
shared
i encourage you to visit our website for
more info
another one yes assuming this is open
data
are you tracking who is using these
images will be nice to see the
applications
um well for the we definitely have a
research program
um where universities do different um
studies and like applications with our
data and those are
uh available through paper and
scientific publications
um i'm not sure if we have that
um like listed or grouped on our website
but i'm sure if you
um search for that on the internet just
pay for some
scientific publications you will find
some of them
not many of them
i am
controlling a world satellite fleet from
a couch is awesome but does it bring
additional security risks
yeah of course um our um security team
make sure that
you know there are all the um security
measures in place so that we can
be able to do this so it's not as easy
as
going to the website for instance but
they make our systems easy
to work with for us
cool um i think there is no more
oh no yeah there's no other question
so thanks again katya was very
interesting
thanks valentina thanks everyone for
inviting me